hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar which is
titled
analytical limitations of hemoglobin a1c
factors to consider when choosing an
hemoglobin a1c methodology
my name is david sacks and i am
moderating
today's effect event
the educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and is brought
to you
courtesy of sabia incorporated
a few items before we begin i encourage
you to participate
by submitting questions at any time you
want
during the presentation to do this
simply type them into the ask a question
box
at the bottom and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
please click on the support tab which is
the top right of the presentation window
or you can report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
the presentation is educational and
offers continuing education
credits to obtain these click on the
continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
there will be three talks today each
talk will be approximately 15 minutes
with time to address the questions
at the end after all three speakers have
completed
i'll be speaking first i'm a senior
investigator and chief of clinical
chemistry at the nih
i'd also like at this time to introduce
our other speakers randy little
is direct of the diabetes diagnostic
laboratory
network coordinator of the ngsp
and professor of pathology and
anatomical sciences
at the university of missouri the third
speaker
is kelly doyle who's the medical
director of
special chemistry and endocrinology and
assistant professor
at the university of utah school
for complete biography of the speakers
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
so with that let's go ahead and get
started
so i'm the first speaker the title of my
talk
is diabetes overview and
role of hemoglobin a1c
now before there was a covet pandemic
there was a global diabetes pandemic
this slide depicts that this is from
a paper published in 2005
on the vertical axis of years and the
horizontal axis
are the number of people in the world
with diabetes and you can see there was
a very dramatic increase
in the numbers as we went from 1985 to
2005
and they predicted at that time that by
2030 there would be
approximately 350 million people in the
world
with diabetes well the most recent
estimates from 2019
from the international diabetes
federation
showed that in 2019 we
far exceeded that number there were
already
463 million people in the world with
diabetes
and by 2045 it is expected
that there'll be 700 million people
with diabetes globally
where are these people well this lists
the top 10 countries for diabetes
most recent data are from 2019
and you can see that the two most
populous countries in the world
china and india are ranked number one
and two
respectively and the usa which always
likes to be first in everything in this
table comes in third which is
not where you want to be ideally
your country should not be in the top
10.
so with that background in mind
let's pose a question
why do we need to diagnose diabetes
the reason we need to diagnose diabetes
is that many people in the world with
diabetes are undiagnosed
it is estimated that in the u.s and
europe
between 30 and 40 percent of people
who have diabetes do not know that they
have it
in china the numbers are estimated to be
between
50 and 60 percent and globally
it is believed that approximately half
or 50 percent
of all people with diabetes neither they
nor their doctors know that they have
diabetes
and unfortunately there's an
approximately seven year gap
between the onset of the disease and the
diagnosis
and because of this delay
at the time of diagnosis 25 to 30
percent
of patients with diabetes already have
irreversible complications
now this is very very important so
between a quarter
and almost a third of all patients at
the time
they diagnosed already have
complications
that cannot be reversed and importantly
studies have shown that treatment can
significantly reduce
or perhaps even prevent the onset of
complications
what are these complications well
they can conveniently be divided
into macrovascular complications which
affect the large blood vessels
and microvascular complications which
affect the small blood vessels
let's start with the microvascular
complications
retinopathy which affects the eyes
is one of the two most common causes of
blindness
in the developed world nephropathy which
causes kidney damage is the most common
cause for chronic renal failure in the
world
and is the most common reason people
go on dialysis
neuropathy causes pains in the
in the predominantly the lower limbs
and then the macrovascular complications
shown in green
affect the brain and the heart and these
are the most common causes of diet of
death in diabetes
causing strokes and heart attacks
now a landmark study published in 1993
the dcct
or diabetes control and complications
trial
showed in individuals with type 1
diabetes they had 1441 patients
and because they have type 1 diabetes
they were all treated with insulin
but they randomly divided them into two
groups
one group received intensive insulin
therapy
the other group received conventional
insulin therapy
and as you would imagine the patients
who got
intensive therapy had better control of
their glucose better glycemic control
this shows the development of
complications in the dcct
the vertical axis is the rate of
complications
and each pair going from left to right
are microvascular complications first
retinopathy nephropathy and neuropathy
and then the last pair are the
macrovascular complications
in pale blue are the patients on
conventional therapy
and read the patients on intensive
therapy
and it's very clear that there's a
significant reduction
in all the microvascular complications
in those patients who received intensive
therapy
there was a tendency towards lower
complications
of the macrovascular
vessels but this was not significant at
the time the study was ended but
subsequently later follow-up showed that
heart attacks were also significantly
reduced in this group
now let's talk about glycated proteins
glycation is the non-enzymatic of a
enzymatic addition of a sugar to minor
groups of proteins
this was first described in the food
industry
and the browning of the toast
and the nice browning on the outside
of this beef are both due to glycation
now probably all proteins in the body
are glycated
but we measure glycated hemoglobin
because it's very easy to get blood
samples
and what's measured currently is
hemoglobin a1c which specifically
has glucose attached to the n-terminal
valine
of the beta chain of hemoglobin
hemoglobin can be glycated at other
regions but these are not hemoglobin a1c
the concentration of hemoglobin a1c in
the blood
depends on only two things it depends on
the concentration of blood glucose
and on the lifespan of the red blood
cell
now because this averages approximately
120 days
the hemoglobin a1c represents the
integrated or average glucose
over the preceding 8 to 12 weeks
so why do we measure hemoglobin a1c well
there's several
several reasons the hemoglobin a1c
concentration in the blood
is used to monitor long-term glycemic
control glucose value as i mentioned
over the preceding
8 to 12 weeks and the hemoglobin a1c
concentration
is used to adjust therapy
the target for most patients is to try
to
get hemoglobin a1c concentration below 7
it is also used to evaluate new
therapeutic agents for diabetes
and when clinical studies are done the
regulatory bodies for example the fda
food and drug administration in the us
look to see if there's a significant
change in hemoglobin a1c before they
approve
the new medication
very importantly hemoglobin a1c is a
measure
of the risk for the development of
microvascular complications
it is the best measure for this and is
significantly better than measuring
blood glucose
that is depicted in this slide which is
also from the dcct
and shows the value of hemoglobin a1c
very dramatically on the vertical axis
is the rate of progression of
retinopathy
which as i mentioned is one of the
microvascular complications of diabetes
and is very easy to diagnose by looking
in the eye
the horizontal axis is the time during
the study
and each one of the colored curves
depicts
a different hemoglobin a1c concentration
so it is evident that those patients
whose hemoglobin a1c concentration
was 7 percent had very very minimal
development of retinopathy
conversely a relatively small increase
in hemoglobin a1c
for example going from seven to nine
percent
resulted in a very dramatic increase in
the rate of progression of retinopathy
and for each one percent change in
hemoglobin a1c
there was a 35 increase in
the progression of retinopathy
the dc ct and its continuation which is
called the edic
also showed that higher hemoglobin a1c
predicts mortality
the vertical axis is the relative
mortality rate
the horizontal axis is the mean
hemoglobin a1c
and it is evident that once hemoglobin
a1c
exceeds nine percent there's a very
sharp and steep increase in mortality
so the last question i'm going to pose
is can hemoglobin a1c be used to
diagnose diabetes
so how does one answer a question like
this
well the first approach would be to
consult the experts
so this is a report published in 2003
and we know that this is a group of
experts because they even call
themselves experts this is the expert
committee
on the diagnosis and classification of
diabetes
and they said in 2003
the committee believes that it is still
premature to add hemoglobin a1c
to the group of tests used for the
definitive diagnosis of diabetes
this question was next evaluated in 2009
six years later by an international
expert committee
and their conclusion was
that the hemoglobin a1c assay may be a
better means
of diagnosing diabetes than measures of
glucose
so what persuaded them in the space of
six years
to completely change the recommendations
and if one reads this paper carefully
you can see that the
expert committee said in 2009
an updated examination of the laboratory
measurements
of glucose and hemoglobin a1c
indicates that with advances
in instrumentation and standardization
the accuracy and precision of hemoglobin
a1c
assays at least match those
of glucose essays and the next speaker
dr randy little will address this
in some detail so with that i'd like to
summarize diabetes is clearly a global
pandemic
can't be treated with a vaccine
it is estimated that approximately 50
percent of patients who have diabetes
have not been diagnosed
and it's very important to identify
these persons
as treatment can reduce or perhaps even
prevent
complications and finally hemoglobin a1c
has a fundamental role in both the
diagnosis
and management of diabetes
thank you
welcome to the second presentation of
this webinar series
my title is choices in hemoglobin a1c
testing
in this presentation i'll be discussing
three things
standardization of hemoglobin a1c
available methods and interferences
the story of hemoglobin a1
standardization really begins with the
results of two landmark clinical trials
the diabetes control and complications
trial
or dcct and the united kingdom
prospective diabetes study or uk
pdf studies of patients with both type
1 from the dcct and type 2
from uk pds diabetes
demonstrated conclusively that glycemic
control
as estimated by serial hemoglobin a1c
determination
predicts risk for complications
and that early good control has long
lasting benefits
this was actually named the
legacy effect
the graph in the bottom on the bottom
right shows one example of the
relationship
between glycemic control and
complications
the increase in retinopathy during the
dcct
is shown on the y-axis not only does the
risk of retinopathy
increase over time on the x-axis
but the rate of progression was clearly
also related to
mean hemoglobin a1c during the study
note that the rate of retinopathy
progression was much
greater with increasing hemoglobin a1c
shortly after the dcct clinical
organizations began recommending
specific treatment goals based on
hemoglobin a1c
the american diabetes association
recommends less than seven percent
for most people with diabetes and this
was true at the end of the dccp
and it's still the recommendation today
so how good were hemoglobin a1c assays
in 1993
when the dcct ended these graphs showed
data from the college of american
pathologists
for two specimens in 1993.
one in the non-diabetic range and one in
the diabetic range
each point represents the mean of
laboratory results for
one hemoglobin a1c assay method
and the bars are plus minus 2sd
the yellow dashed line shows the dcct
result for each sample
results were being reported in different
units in 1993
percent hemoglobin a1 percent hemoglobin
a1c and percent
total glycated hemoglobin as you can see
on the um by the different symbols in
the graph
and you can also see that results were
highly variable
both within and between methods
clearly these results would not be
clinically useful
clinically useful for treatment to
specific hemoglobin a1c goals
a single result could vary from about
2.5
to 7.5 or from 9
to 20 percent
it was extremely important to
standardize measurement of hemoglobin
a1c
given the dramatic results from the bcct
in 1996 the ngsp was developed
from the work of an aacc subcommittee
the purpose of the ngsp is to
standardize hemoglobin a1c results
to those of the diabetes control and
complications trial
and united kingdom prospective diabetes
study
these two studies establish the direct
relationship between
hemoglobin a1c level levels and
outcome risks in patients with diabetes
this is a schematic view of the ngsp
you can see details of the network and
the process
on the ngsp website
basically there's a an ngsp steering
committee
an administrative core and a large
laboratory network which currently
includes laboratories in the u.s
europe japan and china the ndsp is
traceable to the ifcc network
through twice yearly monitoring of the
two networks
the ngsp process consists of calibration
certification
and proficiency testing i'll be focusing
on
certification and proficiency testing
for purposes of this presentation
the current certification process and
criteria are as follows
40 fresh or fresh frozen whole blood
samples are compared
in order to pass certifications 36
of 40 single results must be within plus
minus 5 of the srl mean
the srl is a secondary reference lab
in the ngsb network
we also do lab certifications
the level 2 lab certification criterion
is the same as for manufacturers
and level one is a little bit tighter
with a
requirement of 37 out of 40 results
within five percent
over the 20 plus years after the dcct
hemoglobin a1c measurement improved
tremendously
from chaos in 1993.
you can see that in the first panel of
of the
graph this is the same as the
graph i showed you previously for a
non-diabetic sample in 1993.
again this is cap survey data each
section
includes a single proficiency testing
sample
and each point and bar are the mean
plus minus 2sc for a specific
hemoglobin a1c method
you can clearly see improvement in bias
and variability in hemoglobin a1c since
1993
at the ndsp titan certification criteria
the cap tightened their past fail limits
the table at the bottom shows the
corresponding cash limits
at the time of each survey
currently as you can see below the 2020
graph
the task limit is plus minus 6
but with an educational grade of plus
minus 5
which corresponds to the ngsp
manufacturer certification criteria
this is another way that we monitor the
overall variability in hemoglobin a1c
by combining all cap data for each
sample
this slide shows the percent cv
for all reported results for a given
sample in
each survey all the method data
is combined this graph is
is for samples in the six to eight
percent a1c
range from 2002 to 2020.
you can see a decrease in the all method
cv
from about 5 to less than 3
most recent survey data
code results all methods see these at
2.7
and 2.9 percent
if you want to get a kind of a close-up
of
these data you can look on the ngsp
website
all the cap surveys are
shown there this is one particular
proficiency sample from the second
survey in 2020
the target value for this sample was
7.81
and you can see results for each method
if you look on the website you can
actually
see the method that belongs to each
point
and plus minus 2sd
the shaded bar shows the
pass fail
cap limit of plus minus six percent and
you can see that most
results really do fall within plus minus
six percent
of the ngsp target value
so when choosing a method it's not only
important to look at
sort of whether a method is certified
but it's also
important to look at proficiency data
such as
the cap survey to see how the method
performed
in clinical labs
now on to the second topic of available
methods
there are several different method types
ion exchange chroma chromatography
specifically hplc capillary
electrophoresis
orinate affinity binding or hplc
immunoassay and enzymatic methods
and different method types
can measure different glycated
components
either total glycated hemoglobin
forbornate affinity methods or
hemoglobin a1c
specifically all results
are reported as hemoglobin a1c
you can see looking at these pictures
that there are large instruments
large analyzer that analyzers that
in assay uh different things not only
hemoglobin a1c
medium-sized instruments such as hplc or
capillary electrophoresis
down to the smallest point-of-care
instruments that are dedicated to
hemoglobin a1c measurements
when choosing a method we recommend that
you start with an ngsp
certified method if you go to the ngsp
website and click on certified methods
and labs
and then click list of certified methods
you'll see a list of methods that have
a specific lot numbers that were used
for certification
methods need to be certified every year
the manufacturer gets a certificate
that specifies the
date of the certificate and when it
expires
so when choosing a method ngsp
certification indicates performance at
the manufacturer level
proficiency testing data show actual
performance
in clinical laboratories platform
size for each method type varies from
small point of care methods
to large clinical analyzers interference
our
interferences are method specific
we cannot generalize by method type
so it's important to address
interferences with
each specific method some methods
indicate the presence of a variant
for example hplc or capillary
electrophoresis
with these methods you can see a
specific
peak for the most common variants but it
doesn't always mean that there's no
interference
now to interferences primarily
we focus on interference from hemoglobin
variance
there's a section on the ngsb website
under the tab
more about hemoglobin a1c and then
hemoglobin assay interferences
the listing that you see initially shows
four most common hemoglobin variants as
well as
elevated fetal hemoglobin and
carbamylated hemoglobin
on this first page page you can see
whether or not there is a clinically
significant
interference with the most commonly used
methods
if you then click on more comprehensive
information
you'll see more a detailed table with
references for each entry
so there are more methods listed and
with each yes or no for interference
from a specific variant
you can look up the exact reference
and evaluate the data for yourself
in summary the change to tighter
criteria for ngsp
certification and corresponding cap
survey grading changes
have led to a lower overall variability
in hemoglobin a1c results for patient
care
there are many different types of assay
methods for measuring hemoglobin a1c
performance is method specific
the ngsp website contains up-to-date
information on certified methods
method performance by looking at cap
data
and method interferences
interference from hemoglobin variance is
again method specific
this interference is still a concern for
many commonly used methods
but there are many methods also that
have no interference from common
variants
or and or if they can detect the
presence of these variants
the ngsp continues to monitor laboratory
performance of hemoglobin a1c
and also evaluate new methods for
interference from the
most common hemoglobin variants
laboratories need to consider ngsp
certification status
proficiency testing performance variance
interference
and also their patient populations
especially as far as the prevalence of
hemoglobin variants
when choosing an assay method for
hemoglobin a1c
thank you
hello and welcome to the third portion
of this webinar series
while the title of my presentation is
choosing
an h1c method for your laboratory and
population
i will not focus on choosing a single
analyzer or method
but we'll discuss what to consider in
developing a comprehensive
a1c test offering for your patients and
providers
specifically today i will speak about
considerations across
the process specific to a1c testing and
then propose a few
workflow considerations uh first let's
touch on
the growing utility and benefit of a1c
testing
as an example a1c testing is being
incorporated into
national goals established by u.s health
and human services
this is the healthy people 2030 campaign
where a1c will be a gauge to monitor how
well the u.s is able to curb
the rates of diabetes as well as to
service the target metric
for improving the health of those
diagnosed with diabetes
over the next decade
and because a1c reflects average
glycemia over
approximately three months the american
diabetes association
recommends measurements every two to
three months depending on
whether the patient is meeting glycemic
targets
mounting evidence certainly indicates
that this recommendation is beneficial
to the patient
as well as in decreasing payer costs
associated with hospitalization of
diabetic patients as shown in this study
by a physician group
in the new york area where they saw an
annual cost benefit of nearly two
thousand dollars per year
per diabetic patient when quarterly a1c
measurements
are conducted in their network
so as we get into our discussion about
choosing an a1c method for your patients
and providers
it is critical to think about this
across a full testing spectrum
and this includes considerations for
near patient testing
routine hospital lab testing as well as
the need to rely
on a reference laboratory for additional
testing purposes
it is also important to understand that
across these testing locations
various a1c methods may be applied each
with their
own benefits and limitations some
limitations will not have solutions for
a specific patient
and alter alternate methods or markers
may need to be used to assess the
glycemic control in these patients
so as a laboratorian or a pathologist
it is important that we keep three
groups in mind as we choose
an a1c method and overall a1c testing
solution
certainly patient and provider needs are
paramount
but it's also important to keep the
laboratories needs in consideration
although i'm sure as many of you have
seen laboratories often go to
extreme measures to make it beneficial
and be flexible to put the needs of the
patients and physicians first
so when considering the impact of
testing on these three groups i find it
very useful to break down
the testing into three main phases of
the test process
as you would when deriving a risk
assessment of a laboratory test
those phases being the pre-analytic
analytic and
analytic testing phases
overall the ideals that you're
considering and the ideal place you want
to be with a1c testing
include minimizing cost to the payer and
to the laboratory
optimizing turnaround time assay
accuracy
assay interference a suitable lab
workflow
and appropriate test where the testing
will be performed
and of course utilizing a standardized
method as dr little
did so well at describing to us
so in general let's first discuss some
considerations
in in choosing an a1c method
first a1c specific considerations and
specifically the intent of testing
the lab should consider whether testing
options will be needed
for only monitoring glycemic control or
diagnosis of diabetes
or both as not all a1c methods are
approved for diagnosis
because hemoglobin gene mutations are
common across the world's population
the lab must also consider how their
patient demographic
might be affected by specific a1c test
platforms
lastly health conditions can certainly
influence a1c measurements in ways that
are
both method specific as well as method
independent
vendor literature as well as
resources from the national
glycohemoglobin standardization program
ngsp and national institute of diabetes
and digestive
and kidney disease summarize method
specific limitations and can be very
helpful
through laboratorians
specifically when selecting an aoenc
method the lab's first and foremost
priority should be to determine
whether the method is certified by ngsp
as recommended by both the ada
and world health organization these
methods are traceable to the diabetes
control and complications trial
dcct reference values
again the ngsp website lists all
certified platforms
more practical considerations will
include
assay susceptibility to interferences
and the ability of the test platform
to detect or avoid interferences
additional considerations include sample
throughput maintenance
requirements and certainly cost to the
pair in the laboratory
additional general considerations
include an assessment of
locally available resources and
established
laboratory workflows adding a1c to
existing instrumentation that has
additional test capacity and redundancy
has many advantages may even allow for
automation and integration into an
already
streamlined process as with
any new test offering ip resources
capabilities and functionality must also
be considered
lastly recognizing that any a1c method
may have interferences or limitations
i believe it's very important to
understand what tests are available from
your
reference laboratory and how they might
be of assistance
the goal of the laboratory in the
pre-analytic phase of a1c testing should
be to enable the provider to select the
most appropriate test for the individual
patient
it is critical to recognize that there
are biological factors that can
interfere with the actual measurement of
a1c
and there are other factors that can
influence the interpretation
of the a1c result these biological
factors
may be method dependent or method
independent
the status of the patient's health and
past medical history
can help navigate acid dependent
limitations
for instance a provider may already know
that a patient
has a particular hemoglobin variant
especially if this patient is being
thoroughly monitored for glycemic
control
the provider may also know that this
variant interferes with their
in-house methods that are readily
available to them
in this situation it would be most
prudent for the provider to have the
ability to order an alternative method
at order entry to avoid the risk of
erroneous test results as well as to
minimize
extra cost and prolonged turnaround time
the provider may also already know that
a patient has a variant that does not
interfere with their in-house methods
however even in these situations the
provider
may or may not appreciate that the
variant that is not
analytically interfering may still
influence the a1c result because of the
variant's influence on
red cell survival and how that will
impact the final
a1c result
because a1c results are dependent on red
cell survival
to accurate reflect average blood
glucose concentrations
any changes in the red cell lifespan may
result in an a1c
measurement that fails to accurately
reflect average glycemia during the
previous
120 days or so other factors that affect
glycation
and are independent of the method used
include recent transfusions anemias
polycythemia
pregnancy renal impairment as well as
individuals with homozygous or compound
heterozygous variants
so the priority in the pre-analytic
phase
should be to enable the provider with
appropriate test options order entry
ideally
it should be apparent at order entry
whether options are for
monitoring versus diagnosis what the
testing platform
is that will be utilized for the test
that they chose
and the limitations of those methods
should be outlined for that physician as
well as alternative
tests available to order
each a1c method has unique challenges to
consider in the analytic
phase of testing and it's important to
consider
that some a1c method vendors actually
have multiple
assays that are different and they're
commercially available
and each will have its own advantages
and challenges
there are many resources however
available in the literature and online
and these resources do a great job at
describing assay specific interferences
the ability of the system to recognize
when an interference is present
and if that system is actually capable
of withholding results
if an interference is detected some
systems can also detect an interference
while still providing an accurate aoc
result
the vast majority of errors related to
reporting and accurate
results can often be avoided by simply
integrating
the instructions and guidance that many
manufacturers provide
and integrating those into the
laboratory standard operating procedures
laboratories should also consider
providing resources and tools
to their staff to enable them to know
how to address specific interferences
tools such as
job aids reference charts prior results
and
validation data can certainly help
in the reference lab setting it's not
uncommon for us to receive samples that
were first tested at the primary site
and found to have an interference by
that their method
so it can be very helpful for labs to
know what instrumentation a reference
laboratory is used
and when those methods should be used to
avoid reporting out incorrect values
when an interference is present
now the post analytic phase of testing
is another opportunity for
us to communicate back to the provider
and provide guidance as needed
a number of elements can and probably
should be included in the full result
report
however it's really important for us to
keep in mind that the lab
results in many electronic health
records only display the final result of
the test
and notes or comments are often only
seen if a provider clicks into that
result to investigate
so it's prudent to only display a result
for a1c
when there's complete confidence in the
results if there's any concern about the
accuracy of the result
a placeholder in the result field such
as a comment like
the node will direct the provider to the
comment section of the report
the report can or should include the
following elements as well
the test method used information about
detected variants
published metrics for diabetes for the
diagnosis or
even glycemic targets which may
or may not be institutionally derived or
maybe from
published guidelines and lastly the
report should be
clear to both the provider and the
patient
if a method interference is observed and
cannot be resolved
the lab should make recommendations for
appropriate follow-up testing
or have this set up as a potentially as
a reflexive test
also the report can direct providers to
know what alternative methods are
available to monitor
monitor glycemic control such as
fructosamine glycated albumin or
anhydroglucitol
so in situations where a lab method
cannot directly detect hemoglobin
variants
the lab can still provide some guidance
to physicians on detecting
potentially erroneous a1c results
this guidance may be included in the
result comments on the report or
on an informational lab page
for example some reasons to be
suspicious of an a1c result include
observing that a self-monitored glucose
does not correlate with the a1c result
an a1c value greater than 15 or
less than 4 percent or a significant
change in
a1c results by two different methods
um there is additional guidance on the
niddq website
for patients and providers the only
problem with this approach is that
it's really trying to detect a false
result instead of
avoiding it and largely their
responsibility
rests with the physician to be able to
detect these issues
so to finish up my presentation i just
want to talk about a few more
suggestions in the literature
as to how labs might consider setting up
workflows for a1c testing to avoid
erroneous reporting we will quickly
cover a few of those ideas here
one idea is that for patients who are at
a higher risk
for variance hemoglobin electrophoresis
could be performed first as a screen
if the result is normal essentially any
a1c
test would suffice the lab could also
choose to employ
a hemoglobin or excusing a method that
is capable of identifying common
variants
or having algorithmic or reflexive
testing to have the specimen analyzed by
other methods
when the result is suspected to be
incorrect
to summarize uh this topic of choosing
an a1c method for your laboratory
it is certainly important to keep in
mind and to consider
as you would a risk assessment the
pre-analytic analytic and post-analytic
phases of the testing
process we should also always keep in
mind the impacts to the patients
the providers and also to our
laboratorians
choose only ngsp approved methods
and provide a comprehensive solution to
ensure the most accurate
and appropriate results are provided
thank you for joining me today
thank you randy and kelly for your
informative presentations
we'll now start the live q a if you have
a question
click on the answer question ask a
question box
located in the far left of your screen
and we'll try to answer as many of your
questions
as time permits so let's get started
the first question
[Music]
is can you comment on the impact
of chemically modified hemoglobin
acetylated and cobamulated on different
methods
thanks kelly if you wouldn't mind
addressing that question
yeah certainly so not every method will
be
affected by either acetylated or
carbenylated
hemoglobin a1c but i
would certainly point anyone who is
considering a different hemoglobin a1c
method
to the ngsp website where dr little had
demonstrated that there are uh resources
and tables available
that actually reference literature and
references in the literature to
help guide and provide guidance as to
which specific assays have
interferences
thank you next question
is what would be the hemoglobin a1c high
cut off value
where the medical treatment would not
change no matter how high the value is
i'm i'm i'm happy to address that um
i don't believe that there is a high
cut-off for hemoglobin a1c
the current recommendations from
most clinical diabetes organizations
is that hemoglobin a1c goals should be
individualized as much as possible
depending on
the patient's other conditions the
patient's age the patient's clinical
status but
in general most
younger people the the target is less
than seven percent
as uh randy has mentioned and
certain other groups you know elderly
for example
or people who have visual problems that
the target could be a little higher to
to avoid hypoglycemia but
in general there is no the the
clinicians always try
to to lower the hemoglobin a1c
as as much as is safely possible
the next question this is for randy
hello dr randy this is eduardo from
mexico
could the labs consider the use of
different hemoglobin a1c methods
in case of an unusual result
um i guess it depends on the unusual
result and what method came up with that
unusual result but it's
it's if there's discrepancy for example
with
a clinical impression or
[Music]
something in the patient's medical
history
it would definitely be good to try a
different method type
um that's about
all i can suggest
it might also be good to
do analysis where you can see
hemoglobin variance the presence of
variance in case that wasn't
done in the original method
thank you um randy to stay on the line
the next question um i think
you could address what would be a
realistic goal
cv for testing it seems that vendors
just improve
method every time cvs are lowered
that's definitely a good thing and the
cvs are getting lower
for a single uh laboratory the
the cv should be less than
two percent um of course it's also
good to um and that should be
within the single laboratory
we look at the overall cv which we're
aiming for less than three percent
right now but that's uh all methods
combined so in a single laboratory less
than two percent it's recommended
the next question i think kelly this is
directed to you
since you at a reference lab if you send
out
an a1c to reference lab would it be
a redundant result if they use the same
method
yeah i would i would say that we should
avoid or
we should at least understand what the
reference laboratory's capabilities are
and what test
platform they're using to avoid the risk
of
of repeat testing on the same patient on
the same sample
just because of the fact that you would
be expecting a redundant result
and not only that but then you're
increasing the turnaround time of
communication back to the client and um
as well you're increasing the cost to
the provider or to the to the end payer
certainly
the next question either one of you can
can address this
it is known that the average lifespan of
erythrocytes in beta thalassemia is
reduced
therefore is it important to use a
method that separates and quantifies
hemoglobin a12
indicating to the doctor that the
patient may have beta thalassemia
um this is uh randy little i'm not
sure that that's totally true with um
beta sound minor i don't think
that interferes with most methods
um so i
i'm not sure what else to say but if
there
is interference with one method there
may not be
with another unless the red cell
lifespan truly is affected
okay the next question there are methods
that do not have
interferences with hemoglobin variants
however they are not
alerted to the physician do you
recommend using a method that identifies
hemoglobin variant
i i don't think that's necessarily
that important if you know that the
method
does not have interference with the most
common variants
but many labs including ours like to see
that the
interference is present and and what it
is
labs may report the presence of the
variant
regardless of whether their method
interferes and
some labs choose not to
kelly do you have any comments
yeah i'd like to comment on that as well
i think going back even
to an earlier question that was posed
and that was with respect to a higher
a1c limit and
um and therapeutic intervention and that
i think the clinicians are
going to be in tune a bit with their
patients and and recognize when a result
doesn't necessarily match up
with uh medical history or even
self-monitoring
glucose and in those situations you
would hope
that the the clinician would clue into
the fact that maybe there's
um some issue with with the hemoglobin
life
or the red cell lifespan or hemoglobin
variant and that might trigger them
to order something that might detect a
specific hemoglobin variant or they go
directly to
hemoglobin electrophoresis in those
situations
okay there's another question about
thalassemia i think we've addressed
that could you give more details about
the influence of variance on red cell
half-life thanks
i can try to answer that as far as
we know with uh heterozygous common
heterozygous variants
the red cell lifespan is not affected
and so we generally report
results for patients with these um
varying traits as long as it doesn't
affect the method now with uh
the homozygous variants there usually is
a red cell life span effect so
you would never report an a1c
on any of the homozygous variants
um due to time constraints i'm going to
just take one more question this is the
last question
can you please provide other accepted
methods of measuring long-term glucose
control
for example our lab uses fructosamine
when a1c cannot be accurately measured
are there better alternative methods
i think that we do have a glycated
albumin
method that's fda approved and
that method from japan is
is a good method and at least as good as
measuring fructose i mean
okay well thank you again
randy and kelly for your insightful
presentations
i also uh thank michelle ashton at lab
sorry at lab roots
for seamlessly arranging the audio
visual presentation
and of course our sponsor sabi
incorporated for underwriting today's
educational webcast
finally i want to thank the audience for
joining us today and
for the good questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration please
indicate in your question which person
you would like
to uh answer your question and finally
the webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will elude alerts you by email
when it's available for replay
i encourage you also to share that email
with your colleagues
who may not have had the opportunity to
view today's live
event thank you very much
goodbye